you want to be a mom someday yes I can't
wait to be a mom even though I'm 15 I
would love well that dream already came
true but a happily ever after maybe next
because the source tells Ichi Kylie
Jenner and Boo Travis Scott are talking
more kids and marriage yes the couple
who already shares one year-old daughter
stormy want to expand their little fam
the source tells ET Kylie and Travis
have discussed marriage and their future
together from early on in their
relationship and Travis is planning to
propose eventually quote Travis's told
friends how much he loves Kylie and
wants to propose but he wants to do it
the right way Travis doesn't want to
rush the process they call each other
has been away for they married a fake
age what is the situation you know I'm
literally me Tasker I think we just saw
think like that's like you know what
they call each other the source also
says the pair have talked about adding
another bundle to the bunch
quote both want to have more
Kiley and Travis haven't been shy about
wanting another baby
in fact Kylie has been blatant AF on
social media in February Kylie captioned
this sweet snap with her man baby number
two and in April Kylie shared this
montage of pics celebrating her man's
birthday captioning the pic in part
let's [ __ ] around and have another baby
in June
fans were convinced Kylie and Travis
were already expecting after that video
was posted to Khloe Kardashian's
Instagram
during her 35th birthday bash which
Kylie threw for her big sis you can hear
a woman who fans swore sounded like
Kylie seemingly saying I'm pregnant
but another source confirmed to eat see
at the time that the couple is not
expecting just yet baby okay moving on